foreign
a supermodel and ex-wife of Tom Brady is
now speaking out publicly about her
divorce from the former NFL star you
might say with some truth that it's a
kind of cheap to use this story as
fodder for this segment after all
anytime a celebrity speaks publicly
about a divorce they're guaranteed to
say things worthy of cancellation
celebrities are very often shallow
self-absorbed and stupid and never does
that become more apparent than when they
are trying to publicly rationalize their
failed marriages be that as it may cheap
or not Gisele has earned her spot uh
here today Fox News has a story quote
Brazilian supermodel Gisele Bundchen is
breaking her Silence about their divorce
from former NFL superstar Tom Brady
after 13 years of marriage bunch and
spoke her truth in a tell-all interview
and put a stop to the rumors for good
okay and second thought we have to make
a late addition to the cancellation
whoever wrote this article for Fox is
also canceled because I understand that
this article about a Gisele Bundchen
interview is not meant to be a classic
of American writing I realize it's just
content it's just fodder intended to be
vaguely consumed and then forgotten
about five seconds later but
as someone who is also in the business
of creating internet content can we have
at least a little bit of self-respect
and pride in our craft I mean you packed
three cliches into the first two
sentences breaking her silence spoke her
truth put a stop to the rumors for good
all I'm asking is that you take an
additional 45 seconds to think of a
slightly different way of wording it you
don't have to reach immediately for the
cliche clearance bin and this is
important for everyone on the internet
in the internet content creation space
to understand because they've already
created AI that can write articles
better than this so if you want to have
any chance of surviving you need to be
at least slightly more creative and
interesting and human than a chatbot
but anyway that's neither here nor there
back to the article it says the 42 year
old model said the split was the death
of my dream as she lost who was meant to
be her partner for life
she lost him oh she lost him did she did
you what did she let go of his hand at
the mall did he wander off in the middle
of the night lost him
no she didn't she didn't lose him like
you lose a pair you know a pair of shoes
she chose to leave him as an active
decision I'm not sure to what extent it
was a mutual decision maybe it was maybe
it wasn't but it's certain at least that
she was an active participant in the
divorce she didn't lose anything she
gave up they gave up
but don't tell her that she likes to uh
tell herself that this has all happened
on its own through forces
outside of her control
quote
it's tough because you imagine your life
was going to be a certain way and you
did everything you could you know
bunching a motion emotionally told
Vanity Fair as you wiped away tears I
believed in fairy tales when I was a kid
I think it's beautiful to believe in
that I'm so grateful I did
punching candidly addressed the reason
the former power a couple decided to
split uh after over a decade together
sometimes you grow together sometimes
you grow apart you noted when I was 26
years old and he was 29 years old we met
we wanted a family we wanted things
together as time goes by we realized
that we just wanted different things and
now we have to make a choice
that doesn't mean you don't love this
person it just means that in order for
you to be authentic and truly live that
life that you want to live you have to
have someone who can meet you in the
middle right it's a dance it's a balance
when you love someone you set them free
to be who they are and if you want to
fly in the same direction then that's
amazing
okay let's clear up two things
first if you leave your spouse
it absolutely does mean that you don't
love him the word love has no meaning if
it can apply to a Broken Vow just as
much as it applies to an honored vowel
the way that Gisele defines love the way
that our culture defines It generally is
essentially like this a loving action is
whatever action I happen to be taking at
this moment
to love someone is to do whatever I want
to do
and this is what she means when she says
the word love
it's quite a convenient definition of
the term but it's also meaningless it's
a meaningless definition
love is not merely a feeling and even if
it was merely a feeling you clearly
don't feel too great about somebody if
you want to divorce them but it's more
than that love is a choice it's an act
it's a it's a sacrifice
um
love is an activity you know to love
your spouse is is to be faithful it is
to be loyal it is to be reliable it is
to look out for their physical and
spiritual well-being and so on divorce
is the severing of all of that which is
to say that it is the death of marital
love I mean that's the whole point of
getting divorced
the most important point is that
um a faithful marriage
and a divorce are both choices they are
they are options actively chosen
Giselle talks about marriage using
passive language we grow apart time goes
by sometimes you end up and you know you
end up going in different directions
it's like Tom and Gisele were two pieces
of litter you know a couple of empty
plastic bottles floating in a puddle
randomly bumping into each other and
then drifting off in opposite directions
she talks about like she has no control
over it now in any other situation she
is certain to speak highly and
confidently of her own her own agency
her strength as a Fierce and independent
woman but when it comes to making
excuses for a failed marriage
suddenly she's a helpless flower being
swept Along by the forces of fate
second Giselle claims that her divorce
was a necessary step in the pursuit of
authenticity
she says that in order to be authentic
and to live the life you want to live
sometimes you have to break your
marriage vows and destroy your family
and this is the part that really grates
me the most and why we're talking about
it because we hear a lot about
authenticity these days
and it's always in this context to be
authentic is to be selfish
the authentic path is the most
convenient path
it is authentic to the self in the sense
that it serves the interests of the self
or at least what you perceive your
interests to be
authenticity
not in any meaningful way
if it is authentic it's only because you
are authentically authentically
following your most cowardly and
self-serving and shallowest impulses
but there is a higher authenticity right
there is an authenticity that we should
actually strive towards
and that is the authentic authenticity
of a virtuous life the authenticity of
faithfulness and love and sacrifice
the authenticity of Promises Kept and
vows upheld
true authenticity can be found in the
pursuit of something greater than
yourself
which is what marriage is all about
or what it's supposed to be
and that's what Giselle has abandoned
and that's why she is today finally
canceled that'll do it for this portion
of the shows and move over to members
block you become a member today use code
walls to check out for two months free
on all annual plans hope to see you
there if not talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]